it is truffle season and the place to
enjoy and taste this delicious fungi is
at Eataly Las Vegas at Park MGM and here
to tell us more is Luca Esposito the
general managers good to see you buddy
good to see you okay so what are
truffles uh the truffles are actually
belong to the family of mushrooms but
unlike mushroom they grow underground by
the roots of the trees and that's what
specifically makes them pretty expensive
because there's trained dogs and pigs
that have to hunt for them and so and
one more reason why they're very
expensive it's because they really grow
under very specific weather condition
and these weather conditions are what I
like to call the perfect Italian fall
not too humid not too dry and not rainy
not too hard not too cold so it's the
perfect environment it really gives good
quality truffles is there a region that
has truffles yes you will find them
anywhere from mid-center to Northern
Italy okay uh there's also some other
country that have specific truffles like
France Croatia Australian but what we
have here these are Italian Truffles and
what you're here earlier and everyone
kept saying truffle fries truffle fry
with truffle fries what's the best thing
to put truffles on and also what's the
difference between the two here so here
we have white truffles and burgundy
truffles uh the main difference it's in
the smell uh slightly of course slightly
and uh in the flavor this is more of a
chocolatey uh dry fruit Vibe here we
have something more honey focused
um and this tent is smell a little bit
stronger because the spongy shape really
lets the smell out this one is a little
bit hotter has this grainy look but
ideally the strongest flavor of truffles
is so strong that you really want to
make it the main character of a dish so
what I like to say is that usually you
want to go with a dish that's very
simple like a buttery pasta or cheese
based pasta or egg based pasta when it
comes to Second courses you can do a red
meat uh and last but not least I
actually like to pair my truffles with
gelato oh yeah perfect remember we got
to wrap up here but you have a great
event coming up in Italy we have
truffles and wine mixed together what is
it correct November 18 and 19 a truffle
and wine days for the Truffle you're
going to have a 10 to 30 percent
discount on our offer and these truffles
are not cheap are they they're not how
much does a truffle like this cost uh
there you're around the 400
. no one saw that thank you so much look
I appreciate it what's the website real
quick for the events italy.com I'll give
you back the Truffle there's a new Twist
on you and El Vino up next we